dany langue économiste membre des
économistes atterrés bonsoir dany dans
d'une hausse des dividendes donc aux
actionnaires après plus d'une année de
pandémie est ce que ça vous surprend on
parle quand même de 51 milliards d'euros
ça fait beaucoup
c'est beaucoup mais ça ne me surprend
guère parce que c'est dans la logique du
capitalisme financiarisé dans lequel on
est entré maintenant il ya quatre
décennies et dans ce capitalisme
financiarisé
on est dans cette logique que de
services à l'actionnaire tout est fait
pour verser le maximum de bénéfices aux
actionnaires tout est fait dans une
logique de très court terme
et cette situation de pandémie ne fait
pas exception on pouvait peut-être
s'attendre assez naïvement à ce que les
entreprises
au vu de la situation se calme sur
l'eure là versement de dividendes aux
actionnaires
mais on est dans la droite ligne de ce
qui se fait au fond depuis quatre
décennies où on demande aux entreprises
de verser des dividendes même si elles
n'ont pas les moyens et de d'assurer des
taux de rentabilité délirant entre 17 et
25 %
c'est pas la première fois qu'on entend
parler de ces situations j'aimerais
rappeler qu'avant la pandémie certaines
grandes entreprises fermer certaines
filiales qui ne rapportaient que du 12 %
par an ou du du 10 % par an et qui était
rentable donc on est dans la droite
ligne de cette logique ça se voit un peu
plus parce qu'effectivement comme l'a
très bien souligné votre journaliste ici
on a de l'argent public qui a été
utilisée pour que les rentiers ça
s'accorde un peu mieux la fête
sauf que là il ya eu carrément 22%
d'augmentation à encore plus de
distribution de dividendes que l'année
passée ça peut être très étonnant quand
même en pleine crise sanitaire ça me
dire que ces aides de l'état elles ont
contribué à ce que ça aille aussi bien
pour ses grandes entreprises
les aides de l'état ont été distribués
sans conditions il fallait effectivement
vu de la situation des confinement
apporter une aide de l'état pour éviter
l'effondrement généralisé et d'ailleurs
ce qui m'inquiète
on en a déjà parlé ici sur et retisser
que c'est des prêts garantis et donc que
de ces entreprises n'ont fait que
qu'augmenter leur dette
mais oui à partir de mon nombril n'est
pas de conditions ben ça profite aussi à
des entreprises qui font ça et qui se
font plaisir et qui en général
d'ailleurs payent beaucoup moins
d'impôts sur les sociétés que les pme et
les pmi parce qu'elles savent utiliser
toutes les armes fiscale et tous les
avocats
donc effectivement le bon sens voudrait
que vu la situation se soit calmée mais
le bon sens et la finance sont deux
choses extrêmement différente et là on
voit bien le visage de ce capitalisme
financiarisé qui ne s'intéresse qu'au
court terme et qui ne s'intéressent qu'à
l' qu'au versement de dividendes pour
les rentiers jusqu'à des plans sociaux
commenté dans la presse
c'est un petit peu antinomique autant de
dividendes et ses plans sociaux à ce
moment-là précis mais les plans sociaux
qui est une manière polie de dire que on
va licencier des gens elle s'en
débarrasser ça permet effectivement de
dégager plus de profits et qui dit plus
de profit de verser des dividendes
supérieurs aux actionnaires y voit là on
est dans cette logique où les
entreprises ne sont pas là pour être
soutenable et fait fonctionner leur
activité à long terme elles sont là pour
verser des dividendes de court terme à
leurs actionnaires
j'aimerais quand même rappeler que je
disais tout à l'heure que ces 17 25% 2
de rentabilité qu'on demande aux
entreprises alors que pendant les trente
glorieuses où l'économie fonctionnait
beaucoup mieux et où les entreprises
avec des objectifs à plus long terme on
leur demandait de faire du 3% et c'est
normal parce que on va leur demander de
réinvestir de voir les choses à long
terme d'assurer la croissance et
d'assurer l'emploi on a changé que logic
on pensait qu'avec le confinement et la
crise du capitalisme financiarisé les
choses allaient être amené à changer et
puis là on voit une fois plus cette
logique court terme c'est une logique
peut-être une musique qu'on entend moins
mais mais il ya quand même une bonne
nouvelle c'est que cet argent il est
injecté dans l'économie les ces mêmes
actionnaires paye peut-être des impôts
dans les caisses donc de l'état qui
profite à la collectivité vous
l'admettrez quand même aussi que ça peut
être aussi une bonne nouvelle pour les
français
ben ça dépend quel fond c'est
effectivement pour les rentiers c'est
une bonne nouvelle mais c'est pas les
rentiers qui font fonctionner une
économie ce sont ce sont les
travailleurs en premier lieu c'est à
dire ceux qui produisent de la richesse
et puis ce sont aussi les entrepreneurs
qui eux prennent des risques qui eux se
font souvent pour la plupart en tout cas
les patrons pme et pmi qui se tuent à la
tâche aux 3 à 4000 euros par mois donc
c'est pas les rentiers qui font
fonctionner l'économie c'est et c'est
d'ailleurs en fait bien établi que quand
on donne un euro plus à rentiers il ya
là beaucoup moins qu'ils reparlent en
l'économie que quand on donne à leur
opus à quelqu'un qui en bas de l'échelle
des salaires parce que tout simplement
une dépense donc c'est pas forcément une
bonne nouvelle pour l'économie non
toutes ces 30 tout s'est tu
et d'ailleurs je pense qu'on a un peu
oublié que
les pères fondateurs du libéralisme
voulait se débarrasser de la vente et
des ventes y est les patrons du cac 40
comment se sont ils comportés notamment
sur leurs salaires à ce qu a eu des
efforts en ces temps de crise sanitaire
c'est extrêmement variable et comme le
disait très bien votre journaliste un
patron du cac 40 n'ont pas le sens de la
décence et puis je suppose que
l'argument avancé de la comparaison
internationale
parce que vous comprenez si aux états
unis on gagne 400 fois ce que gagne son
salarié en france a aussi gagné qu'à
cent fois ce que gagne son salarié moyen
ski totalement déraisonnable qui est
absolument injustifié et cetera
évidemment un patron d'une grande
entreprise doit gagner plus que son
salarié moyen mais rien aucune théorie
économique ne justifie qu'il gagne 400
500 fois ce que gagne son salarié de
base et c'est totalement inefficace
parce que c'est de l'argent qui va
partir dans des produits financiers qui
contribue à rendre les économies plus
instable donc on est une fois de plus
dans l'ue brisson est une fois de plus
dans le déraisonnable
ça n'est guère surprenant et il est
temps que les personnes se rendent
compte à quel point ce système est
déconnecté y compris de du bon sens et y
compris des théories économiques qui se
prétend merci dany langue économistes
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur arte
france